is it a spider yeah
it was small yeah it didn't look small
yeah yo when that thing comes down i bet
you it [ __ ] makes it like a batman
thing across the wall that's cute
all right
and did he come down
how far how far down you can put your
phone down
would it touch my head and nobody
decided to kill it
look at you like i'm not such a land
spider
[Laughter]
yeah this dude looks tough and i was
like spider he's like [ __ ] not me are
you okay
what if i was just like
i've eaten live at live insects before
on live on uh i did a tv show a live
show on discovery once where i i had to
eat live cockroaches
yeah that's online it's pretty gross
ah
all right
spiderman
i mean
who'da thought we'd all just be staring
at a [ __ ] spider
[Applause]
like nobody's ever seen one before
[Applause]
[Music]
my man's tatted up from [ __ ] neck to
ankle
[Laughter]
beard it up big dude [ __ ] is that a
spider
that's not what i was expecting from you
man
[Laughter]
that's awesome do you see he moved her
in front of him he was
like that's awesome
i'm the same way dude i'm up
congratulations
you just saved her life
[Applause]
but you know what i do love about how
you were reacting
you had everywhere to go you could have
gone right
and you just went like this
just like like that three inches was
going to be like
you didn't want to interrupt me you
didn't think you're doing this
was interrupting
that's me okay
guys you have to understand man
this type of [ __ ] is what i love about
my job
my job is never the same this that's
never gonna happen again that's never
gonna happen again either
[Applause]
it's [ __ ] great i have a very anxious
dog
here we go
i mean he's not as anxious as this guy
around spiders but he's pretty
[Applause]
yeah so so great
[Music]
something
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]